that Tesla's saying that a
tractor-trailer was crossing a divided
highway and when it was perpendicular
the Tesla hit it one of the key things
of Tesla is saying is that the white
trailer up against a bright sky in the
car as a auto pilot didn't see it and
they're also saying the driver didn't
see it so that's been one of the areas
of this kind of technology that there's
been some things such as snow that these
kind of technology has a hard time
seeing so it's not surprising perhaps
the white background was not picked up
yet not as advertised for this I mean
that some of the features were rolled
out initially in Tesla's auto pilot and
then the company pulled back on some as
I understand it do we know sort of where
this held in terms of that or the
relationship with the development of
Tesla's technology has it been on the
road
well yeah Tesla brought back some of the
technology earlier this year and some
videos turned up on the Internet of
people doing some silly things and
questions of safety really the driver is
supposed to keep their hands on the
wheel and be able to take control as
something goes awry and there's a system
that essentially supposed to slow the
car down if the driver is not paying
attention so we're not sure what's going
on in that regards really what you know
one of the issues of is it currently
going on is about the development of
driverless cars and this technology is
not a driverless car technology there
yet if we are looking at a scale from
zero to four this is probably more in a
two with four being totally autonomous
this is some features such as keeping
the car in a lane and being able to take
your hands and feet off of the pedal and
wheel it would essentially go forward
and slow down if something came in its
way this is interesting I mean you know
Tesla we were looking at video of
Tesla's in snow Tesla has made a point
of trying to say that their vehicles can
handle the situation's initially their
reports as a store the New York Times
about a driver trying to use an early
Tesla Model S who couldn't keep a good
charge in cold weather there's questions
about altitude as well this suggests
this is not an all-purpose vehicle well
you know this kind of technology this
this idea of the kind of using sensors
and cameras to control the car looking
out into the future there there's a been
issues with other technology regarding
snow and rain and those kind of lighting
situations in the human
has a remarkable ability to see things
and it's trying to train the computer to
see that as well and they're still still
kind of developing some of that it's
also interesting you know Tesla's one of
the sort of amazing things about a
Tesla's that updates can happen after
you bought the car the software can be
changed after the car is already in the
field does this suggest that maybe this
wasn't ready for primetime
well it's interesting this this
technology was rolled out last year and
then you know in January that made some
changes some safety updates can limiting
some of the ability of this kind of
going forward we saw earlier this year
so they have the ability to kind of
change the software as they go for much
like your cell phone your iPhone will
update really what this is probably
going to be watched for very closely as
is the conversation about autonomous
cars there's been concerned about you
know having a fatality and what that
would mean to the development of this
technology we saw Valentine's Day this
year when the Google car which is an
autonomous car got into a fender bender
with a city bus in California and that
got a lot of attention and a lot of
concern about what would happen on that
day when somebody dies in a an
autonomous vehicle and and would it
setback this kind of development